why we've been so lucky to have so few
secrets leak on either infinity ward
endgame I lost you because the crew the
massive cast and crew is a family now
and they're all protecting it together
whatever it takes think this has
developed a mythology that there were
radically different scripts they weren't
really we just went through and changed
a few key things so with that we had our
writers create alternate versions you
know you hear some stories of people
shooting multiple endings and shooting
multiple things we had enough to film
but we always thought to be funny to see
them and that is what we present you now
my undying good luck brother
The Sun will shine again shall we pursue
him
ah no need we have all we need
Thanos of Titan hmm the soul of the
universe is yours to hold
[Music]
don't do this
Wanda Maximoff how may I be of
assistance today we have to tear this
place apart II I hear he has to be lying
my father has many things liars not one
of them Thank You daughter perhaps I
treated you too harshly
[Music]
hey everyone it's Charlie Marvel just
released this video of more alternate
post-credit scenes and alternate deleted
scenes things that they played around
with the movie just to mislead people so
they wouldn't know what's actually
happening during avengers endgame in
Avengers infinity war a lot of you were
asking about the Howard the Duck cameo -
they finally revealed exactly where that
is in case you missed it during the
theater so we'll break it all down
there's a new round of the blu-ray
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
Marvel phase 4 theory on the video the
weird thing about all the scenes that
they included in this is that in the
cameo portion of this they didn't put
Stan Lee's cameo in it and it's always
one of the more notable cameos that you
talk about but I suppose this was
supposed to be more of a video about the
people that you might not necessarily
spot most of you probably spotted the
community cameos just because the Russos
are such big community people so they
always pop up in all of their movies
even all the non Marvel movies that they
just announced they're making after
leaving Marvel Post Avengers end game
because they aren't gonna be doing any
more Marvel films for a while at least
until they get back around to Secret
Wars in five or six years Howard the
Duck himself looks like he's coming in
with the Ravagers from contrack sia that
was the planet during guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 with the Howard the Duck
cameo so it's like he's been there
hitting on women ever since that cameo
happened the joke about his name in the
chyron here Howard T Duck is just t
standing for the as in Howard the Duck
he also actually goes by Howard Dutson
and if you forgot they announced that
Kevin Smith and Marvel are making a
Howard the Duck TV show it's gonna be
adult animation but it'll be on Hulu
sometime next year the reason for the
Matthew Barry fantasy football cameo is
this because the Russo brothers are
crazy fantasy football fans in real life
in the Avengers actors even have a
special secret fantasy football league
of their own that they played while they
were making the movies it was so
exclusive that they didn't even let all
the actors participate it was only just
a couple of them most people didn't
recognise ty simpkins either right away
from Iron Man 3 it's just that it's been
so long since that movie came out that
he's a teenager now so of course he
looks a little bit different but in real
life the actor did say that he would
love to come back and play iron lad in a
young Avengers movie during Marvel phase
4 Marvel phase 5 we already got the
phase 4 schedule so if they do wind up
doing a young Avengers movie
we can now say with 99% certainty that
that wouldn't happen until Marvel phase
5 at the soonest in the issue that
they're actually running into with the
Young Avengers movies because they have
Cassie Lang who's a teenager now played
by Emma Furman if they don't wind up
making that young Avengers movie for
long enough then some of these younger
actors will actually age out of those
roles as crazy as that sounds they
actually need to be pretty young to be
in a young Avengers movie so they wait
seven or eight years to make it these
people aren't going to be teenagers
anymore
all the deleted scenes that they
included in this are all pretty wild
they animated these because they cut
them so early in the process so Loki
plays a trick is the name of this first
one basically Loki escaping fan OHS at
the beginning of infinity Bor and then
returning during Avengers endgame I
think I talked about this after avengers
endgame came out there was that other
loki deleted scene there were all these
alternate loci plots that they had
because they knew they were gonna be
doing the loki TV show so they had to
explain how a version of loki could
survive to star in that during Marvel
phase four they wound up landing on the
tesseract Loki explanation so that's
obviously why they went with the version
of infinity world where Loki actually
sacrifices himself and he winds up dying
in the Loki during the TV show is one
who has not had all that character
development that our regular version of
Loki has had so it'd be a little more
mischievous a little bit more of an
having a little bit more fun
with everyone the Gamora scene is called
Gamora shakes it off and it's a version
of events where she survives Stannis is
sacrificed to get the soul stone because
that's part of what the soul stone is
capable of it preserves life after death
so a piece of her soul is stuck inside
the soul stone that's who he's talking
to when he's talking to young Gamora at
the end of infinity we're in that orange
space there was an Iron Man scene that
was just like that in Avengers end game
that they shot what they're saying with
this scene though is that he pulled that
shard of her soul back into the realm of
the living and then continued on his
quest leaving her on for mere stranding
her with the Red Skull one of my
favorite alternate endings for the Hulk
was the alternate ending where we see
him Hulk out of the Hulkbuster when he
still isn't able to become the Hulk
suddenly during the middle of the battle
of Wakanda he's able to do it it came in
this scene here when he was fighting the
Black Order and says fine I'll do it
myself
in that moment he was supposed to Hulk
out of the Hulkbuster then disappears
for a little while and emerges
from the bushes looking like the
professor Hulk like he'd already figured
out how to fuse his personality between
Banner and the Hulk and after that black
widow was going to come up to him and
they were gonna do a reference to
Avengers age of Ultron she was going to
come up to him and say Suns getting real
low big guy and as a way to show that he
had changed he was going to say no
Natasha we don't need to do that anymore
and everybody was gonna freak out on the
theater because the Hulk was suddenly
talking like a normal person
this scene of vision is called the
vision crashes and is basically him
surviving Thanos's attack sure he is
successful in this version of events and
separating his consciousness from the
mine stone so that when Thanos would
have taken it from his forehead instead
of his brain just shutting down in him
dying his systems reboot and he's
effectively reborn as a less aware
version of himself like losing the mine
stone made him lose a piece of his
humanity and he's more of a machine now
we'll talk more about what's going on
with vision during Marvel phase four
when they start dropping more details
about the Scarlet Witch vision one
division TV show there's gonna be a d23
Marvel panel happening later this month
so hopefully they'll reveal some more
details then the scene of Thanos is
called fan OHS keeps it together as in
he keeps his head attached to his body I
guess that's the joke there it's just a
version of events at the beginning of
Avengers endgame where Thor did not go
for the head and instead just knocks
Thanos out with storm breaker and they
try to figure out what they're gonna do
next because he doesn't have the
Infinity stones anymore
my favorite alternate endings that we've
learned about price still the Hulk scene
and then the Living Tribunal versus
Thanos scene from the end of Avengers
infinity war where Doctor Strange is
able to survive the snap and takes
Thanos to be judged by the Living
Tribunal it would have been really weird
and really cool I'm really sad that they
didn't do it hopefully they'll get
really weird with Marvel phase 4 Marvel
phase 5 stuff when we get into really
cosmic eternals level celestial stuff
and then probably one of the best scenes
that we haven't even seen yet is the
scene of Iron Man with his adult
daughter Morgan Stark in the sole world
of the soulstone you can even see her
behind the scenes on set right after
they filmed it here this is Catherine
Lankford playing the adult version of
Morgan Stark so we know that footage
exists hopefully they'll release it at
some point but let me know in the
comments what is your favorite alternate
ending alternate post-credit scene or
just scene that didn't wind up making it
into the movie
you've heard about recently I'm working
on a new Eternals video my spider-man
far from home deleted scenes and more
Marvel phase four so those should all
post really soon but also really good
news Disney just confirmed that they're
gonna be bundling Disney Plus Hulu and
ESPN together for about 13 bucks
surprisingly it's cheaper to buy that
deal than to buy Hulu and Disney Plus
separately but each of those by
themselves is gonna be pretty cheap
we'll learn more about what's going on
with Disney Plus at d23 in a couple
weeks so whatever previews and Marvel
phase 4 stuff they drop I will totally
do videos for it congratulations Jesus
partita you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Marvel video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here to learn all
about what's going on with spider-man 3
and click here for my Thor for love and
thunder teaser video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]